this lumpy chunk of whale vomit is one  of the most valuable substances in the  world it's called ambergris and it forms  inside of sperm whales the substance  forms in their digestive tracts to  protect them from the sharp beaks of the  squid they eat and is excreted like  feces or vomit as the oily substance  floats on the ocean sometimes for up to  a thousand years it hardens into a Musky  aromatic block that's been used in  perfumes medicine and food since the 9th  century and today is still used as the  secret ingredient in Chanel Number Five  it can be sold for up to forty thousand  dollars a kilogram with some chunks  being worth well over a million dollars  and even though we now have synthetic  chemicals to replace it in perfume  ambergris Hunters still Vie for control  of certain beaches as finding a chunk of  it is like winning the lottery